is using a gmail account unprofessional
welcome to their tech Tuesday today I
mention a question for one of my
subscribers love you guys Matt fo who
wrote in the say hi Evan today I had a
very interesting discussion with a
friend of mine she wanted to know why I
use Gmail address her reason was that
email doesn't make a business person
look professional and big business
prefers professional email addresses to
Gmail I said to her whilst I have the
other email address that she considers
professional
I prefer Gmail follow two other benefits
one I don't have the pain annual fee to
I can use Gmail anywhere three my
documents are never lost
before I get to have a whole host of
Google bouquets services five most
people that I interact with are on
Google and it's easier to connect with
them etc I just wanted to know your
thoughts in this matter
regards metaphor this is a great
question and here are my quick thoughts
number one yes gmail is not as
professional all you have to do is a
quick google search for is a gmail
account unprofessional and you'll see
how many people are asking this question
that alone plus what your friend is
telling you means that there is a stigma
against gmail accounts from my own
experience if somebody writes to me to
join my mastermind group or my movement
coaching program or ask me a question
and if they're writing from a gmail
account I'm assuming they don't have a
website and they're just starting out
their business now you may want to take
a stand against that you may want to be
the person says no Gmail is professional
and I'm gonna show the world but my
question for you is is that really a
fight that you want to fight does it
mean that much to you
so right now gmail is not as
professional I'm sorry to disappoint
okay so number two doesn't matter does
it really matter for your business say
you're a piano teacher and you get most
your business from word of mouth and
you're full up on students right now and
you don't really want to grow bigger
than where you are why do you need a
website wining the branded email address
it doesn't matter to you now let's see
your marketing or brand if you don't use
a branded email address and show your
website off then people aren't going to
take you seriously
they'll think how can she market and
brand my business if you can't even do
it for her own there's just a higher
level of expectation depending on what
kind of business you're in here's
another example let's look at headshots
if you're in the junk hauling removal
business people won't really judge too
much what your headshot looks like you
still want to look good but it doesn't
matter so much now if you're a
photographer people will have a much
higher expectation for you to have a
great headshot if you don't people will
think that you're not that great a
photographer so even though gmail is not
as professional does it really matter to
your business but my real answer is
number three do both I have a gmail
address and the regular email address
you can set Gmail to accept all of your
incoming emails from all your different
email addresses that way you still get
all the benefits of using Gmail but you
can also have the professional look and
feel from using your branded email
address if you're not sure how to do it
just Google how to add a pop3 pop3 email
address into Gmail and if you still
can't figure it out shoot me a message
and I'll try to help you out for those
of you watching let me know what you
think do you use a gmail address for
business use or a branded email address
leave a comment below and if you guys
like this video you want to see more
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you soon if you want more entrepreneur
goodness check out the link to my
newsletter below see you there
you